[Music]
this partnership just be burned fiancee
Haley Baldwin
yeah the two lovebirds aren't shy show
us the PDA all over New York City and
just leaving given his ladylove a
compliment over bothy sugar without
adding real sugar we'd also like to add
that he held a door for a mom he's a
good Canadian kid now the Biebs
obviously a bachelor no more the same
cannot be said for the folks in the
upcoming season of bachelor in paradise
but as detailed lines lauren zima found
out they may not stop just in from
tuning in I've met Justin a few times
because his mom Patti is a big fan she's
a huge member of bachelor nation and I
know Justin knows of our show he even
told me one time hey bro
like your show the Biebs is such a big
fan he not only watched last season a
paradise a message several of the
contestants on Instagram and even hung
out with one of them Danielle L he
connected to people that were on
paradise that felt like they're going
through a wall it was really nice he's a
really super
Danielle's not on this season of
paradise but fans can expect to
everything they've come to love about
the guilty-pleasure
bikinis booze backstabbing and tears
having so much fun one contestant ooh
watch out for crystal
she was the villain on re season of The
Bachelor you were so have you changed
grown learned since then I learned to
really clear like emotional space coming
into paradise yeah I've learned a lot of
sage girl did you you've saved what
yourself your house away season 5 is the
shows the longest ever the cash shot in
Mexico for four weeks and ten of the
contestants are from Becca's current
season of The Bachelorette including
male model Jordan so how are you with
those guys the only person guy
potentially might have some trouble with
this is David checking your unning
hiring you lack integrity you said that
you spent six hours hand selecting your
outfits for the Bachelorette how long
did you spend picking out your paradise
wardrobe I spent about two hours last
time yeah and I always spend about 1,200
bucks
[Music]